hello thank you thank you introduction i
am stephanie brodie as was stated i am a
research program specialist at DDOT the
district Department of Transportation
and we also had Kiana interning with us
quite recently she's a PhD candidate at
the University of Maryland and while she
was interning with us she helped to set
up Newman on numerous Python scripts to
understand the Dhokla s-- demonstration
period and how many of you guys have
been in DC and have seen the scooters
that have been out in the streets all
right how many have written them so
thanks for participating in the dhoklas
demonstration period I'll give you a
little brief introduction about what it
is and why we have that going on and
then I'll start talking about some
comparative analysis that looks at the
doclist ministration and the Capital
Bikeshare bike sharing system that we've
had at in DC for quite some time
then Keon I'll come up and she'll talk
about some other analysis that we did
the idle time analysis labeling dhoklas
chips to understand travel behavior a
hotspot analysis as well as showing you
some visualizations that we did to
understand where chips are coming from
and going to
so back 10 years ago DC launched the
first bike share a public bike share
system in the North America's and this
was smart bike DC a couple years later
we upgraded to Capital Bikeshare which
is what you see now out there we have a
we have over 400 stations within the
metropolitan area last year in September
we added a Aquos bike share to that mix
this allowed through a permit process
private entities were able to sprint to
able to rent out bicycles to the public
in public space in March so not long
after the dhoklas bikes came we got bike
backless scooters and these have been in
existence since March and DC and at this
point in time we have mainly scooters we
have five companies operating under the
demonstration period four of them are
scooters and one is
and ESS pedal bike so we wanted to have
this we want to be open to this dhoklas
demonstration period because we want to
increase modal options in the District
of Columbia but we want to make sure
that we're addressing some of our
primary goals like ensuring safety and
increasing active transportation so in
order to understand if this additional
mobility option is doing so we want to
do an evaluation along with the
demonstration period so we had a couple
of key things we want to find out is the
dhoklas demonstration here is the
ductless or doclist options increasing
active transportation goals or
increasing aptitude and active
transportation and aligned with our
goals um
can we ensure that this is adding to the
safety of our transportation system so
are these systems safe also we want to
have a demonstration piece we can gain
some public input as we can understand
what the public thinks about them
because we are serving the public and
finally we've been managing document
managing bike share for 10 years now
but the dhoklas options are new in DC
new across the country and new in a lot
of global markets so we want to make
sure that we are understanding how we
can establish a management system for
this program in terms of managing the
program we as I mentioned have a permit
that companies have to abide by and
there are certain rules in that permit
one of those rules being that they have
to provide data so each company has to
provide a public API that shows where
the bikes are and the bikes or vehicles
bikes or scooters at any point in time
that are available for rental and that
allows people Civic hackers as well as
people who are developing apps and just
general public who are interested in
this in the system to get information
about it we also have monthly reports
that provide trip origin destination
data and that allows us to understand
how we might plan better for our
transportation system as well as
providing for infrastructure for the
ductless vehicle
and getting this data set is really the
beginning so we've had other trips
origin destination data sets and this is
another big large data set that we have
we're trying to do is find ways that we
can use this data to better understand
our planning efforts as well as evaluate
the program and this is the beginning
because there's also data that's coming
in from T and C's which is your
translation network systems that lures
and lists and we want to be preparing
for automated vehicles and autonomous
vehicles which will also be providing
data that can be used for planning
purposes
currently we also have cameras and
sensors in the field in DC that provide
us input that can provide us information
on safety which is again our number one
priority so you want to be able to use
that as well and then there are data
sets across the district and different
agencies that can provide insights that
will be helpful for DDOT going forward
as well so we have a lot of data that's
out there and we're just scratching the
surface of how to use that data to
improve efficiency and safety and
transportation so in this presentation
I'll go through some analyses and so
we'll keanu the first one I'll talk
about is a comparative analysis that
looks at dhoklas bike-share and
comparing it to Capital Bikeshare then
Keanu we'll talk about an adult time
analysis that looks at the impact of
Aquos on public space because DDOT does
manage the public space we'll also talk
about how we label trips to understand
travel behavior patterns and then
finally go through a hotspot analysis
that we use to identify areas for a more
parking infrastructure for bicycles and
also scooters finally we'll do some
visualizations that look at the trip
origin destination data more Raleigh and
to understand where trips are going from
and coming to coming from and going to
so I'll start with the comparative
analysis so what you have here are the
number of monthly trips that were taken
on Capital Bikeshare and dhoklas
vehicles
I'm so again the program started in
September last year and what you'll see
is that around March when the scooters
came we start to see an uptick on
ridership and that is that's because the
scooter chips were dramatically higher
than the doclist bicycles but when you
take away again is Capital Bikeshare is
has a much higher ridership base it has
a lot more vehicles and also a lot more
stations
this shows a heatmap matrix of the rides
going to and from different wards the
city of the district Clara eight wards
in DC war two is the central business
district downtown by the mall and the
monuments Ward seven and eight are
across the Anacostia River and those are
areas that are primarily minority and
low-income so what I want you to take
from these you have Capital Bikeshare on
your left and left and dock with
vehicles on your right so what's
interesting between these two is there
is a comparative distribution across the
district for both vehicle for both
options however many of the trips most
of them in fact are starting in War two
which is downtown the central business
district between Capital Bikeshare and
dhoklas vehicles if you look at the
trips that are starting in Ward 7 and 8
there's a little bit higher percentage
in the in the areas across the river so
that's interesting to note because one
of the things that we want make sure
that we're doing in DDOT is serving the
entire population of the district so
it's important that we're understanding
the benefits to having these systems and
and where they're going
we also wanted to know what kind of
usage trends happen across the week so
here we have the usage trends over the
course of the day for weekdays and
weekends because travel patterns are
different on weekdays versus weekends so
if you look at the weekdays each line
represents a different mode you can see
that for Capital Bikeshare members those
are the people who have memberships to
the station based service and for e bike
riders these to serve these two member
groups tend to have peaks in the morning
and in the evening which denotes a
commuting pattern on the weekend we see
that most of the modes are similar with
some concentration of trips for scooters
within the daytime hours we also wanted
to look at the dish the spatial
distribution of those trips across the
day so this is an example of morning
peak time commuting or morning peak time
usage for Capital Bikeshare members and
then Capital Bikeshare casual riders so
casual riders are those who might have
taken one trip they might buy a pass for
a day but don't have memberships so what
you can see here is the casual riders
are typically concentrating their trips
in the morning downtown by the monuments
by the museums where the members are
more spread out and that also harkens
back to the last slide where we see the
commute patterns with the members if we
then look at the dhoklas vehicles both
the bikes and the scooters we see a more
just a more distributed trip pattern for
the morning we do see kind of the
hotspot downtown in the areas around the
mall but we also see that it's
distributed more broadly across the
residential areas and that's because
they're not constrained to the stations
that Capitol bike shares
to understand some more about how these
trips are distributed across the week we
looked at each of these modes and
identified or and found out that as we
suspected they're fairly discrete across
the week
however casual riders are typically
casual Capital Bikeshare riders are
typically doing most travel on Saturday
and Sunday on the weekend and another
kind of outstanding or outstanding issue
with the casual users is a trip duration
so these users are typically riding the
bikes for longer so we see average trip
duration between 10 and 12 minutes on
most cases except for the casual riders
and their variants is also much larger
so that's a little bit of background on
the Dhokla program capital Capital
Bikeshare and how DDOT tries to
encourage active transportation and kind
of what we found just looking at the
data generally and I'll pass the mics
over to Keanu to talk about the analysis
more specifically
no hello everyone thanks for coming to
our talk so I'm going to continue
talking about some some other analysis
that we have done indeed at Douglass
park chaerin scooter sure
so the first analysis I'm going to talk
about idle time duration so basically
idle time duration refers to interval
between the end of a trip and start of a
trip with the same wake up so basically
this was very important for DDOT because
they initially received several
complaints about the these spikes are
parking for a long time in certain areas
especially blocking the pedestrians or
disabled people so we wanted to find out
in what extent this is true and then
again this was this was used as
measurement for assessing the
performance of the operators in
maintaining this system in DC and the
other potential usage for this kind of
and also it's going to be for locating
where are the proper places for putting
the biking racks and also from
appraisers perspective it's also
important because it can help them to
with their rebalancing operations in
order to have a more efficient system
that can serve many people like they can
serve they can increase the usage so
there are certain libraries that were
used
them and the block for each section so
in order to calculate the idle duration
so we needed to sort the trips based on
the operators and then vehicle IDs and
the start of the trip and then cleaning
procedure was done to basically remove
the irrelevant trip so for example for
example if trip was ended at the
location and then the start of the next
trip was far from this location then it
was removed so basically this was
basically resulted from the rebalancing
of the system or some error in the data
so basically we were remained with
around 67% of the ductless scooters data
and then 70 around 71% of the ductless
bikes so this graph sure shows a part of
our analysis so basically this is the
the x-axis shows the time of day that
the parking event happened or occurred
and then the y-axis shows the duration
of the idle time so basically the lower
bound is 25% island there up around 70
percent percentile and then the line
between it's the median so for example
you can see for Dhokla spikes which is
the green plot you can see around 5 5
a.m.
25% was around 2 hours median was around
5 hours and then the 75% of was around
hours so you can see that the trend
increased for the evening which is
intuitive because most of the bikes they
are not going to be used during the
night time so this kind of increase you
cannot see for scooters so in general
you can see that scooters their idle
duration is much lower which which can
be particularly because they are very
popular and then you cannot see the
nighttime because night the high idle
duration during nights because basically
scooters are usually like mostly
gathered because they are electric to be
recharged so basically the idle duration
during night is removed from the data so
another analysis we have done was to see
what percentage of trips had idled
duration more than 6 hours so these
regions are single member district which
which each of them has around 2,000
residents again as you can see so
southeast of DC has relatively higher
percentage of trips with I the duration
more than 6 hours so these are worth
seven and eight but I'm going to show an
interactive visualization which
indicates that this doesn't basically
interpret as high number of trips
because mostly the most of the trips
happen in War two and six which are
located in city centre and there are not
that many trips in Bart seven and eight
so this is the same visualization for
ductless scooter as you can see again
that the percentage of trips with I
dilution more than six hours is much
lower than
ductless bikes so here it is a
visualization using shiny for locations
with idle time more than six hours so
basically you can select the time of day
for example we pick seven eight and then
we can choose ductless bikes and if we
zoom in we can see that where are the
locations like a heat map of locations
with Idol doers and more than six hours
so if you change that you can see for
example in this area which is mostly a
commercial area you can see a high idle
durations which is intuitive but when
you for example move it to time between
4:00 and 5:00 p.m. you can see that the
intensity of idle durations decrease so
so now we will move to the next analysis
so in this analysis we wanted to
basically answer this question that
whether the behavior of ductless by
train scooter share users is most is
more closely related to Capital
Bikeshare casual riders or members so if
you are familiar with Capital Bikeshare
you know that the turn to kind of
memberships one is casual which is a
daily pass or three-day pass and then
there is another one as annual
membership so in this part of analysis
we wanted to develop a classification
model train based on Capital Bikeshare
data because for Douglas Park
and dr. scooters we don't have a label
such as Capital Bikeshare as member and
Carol so so basically we use two
classification models random forest and
logistic regression with random forces
and on some classification metal and
logistic regression is a linear model
for classification and then we basically
train this model using the Capital
Bikeshare data from March till end up
may 4 to consecutive years 2017 and 2018
there are about 1 million four hundred
thousand trips these are just within DC
trips and how however the the data said
is highly biased towards the members
because usually in Capital Bikeshare
there is a there are there is just some
usually like 70% of the trips are made
with are taken bit by members and 30% by
casual riders to make the data data
balanced with down sample data and then
we were left with seven hundred thousand
seven hundred thousand trips and then
basically we the 20% of this data was
used as a test and 80 percent for
training then we used the model
developed on Douglas parks and Douglas
scooters to label their trips so for
Douglas parks we had around 70,000 trips
and for Douglas scooters
around 180 thousand trips so the
features that were used for training the
model was start and end location which
was mapped to single-member district
level duration of trips start time of
the trips and day after week so in order
to have evaluate the mother f1 score was
used so you can see that around random
forest has a slightly better f1 score
and then at the table and on upper level
shows the confusion matrix for both
logistic regression and random forests
you can see that around for random fires
around 63 thousand out of 76,000 trips
were labeled correctly and this number
was around 64,000 for the members and
then I in the next table you can see the
model prediction for Douglas PI's and
Douglas scooters you can see for example
for random forest the model predicted
that around 60% of the trips are by
members and for darker scooters this is
around six sixty five percent which
shows that mostly by this classification
the trips were more aligned to members
and commuter trips so the last
yes those numbers are those reported on
the downsample like the contestant did
you also down sample
four so given for logistic regression I
ran the first the last one so so
basically you don't have so this is a
unsupervised learning so you don't have
label for this so basically you don't
have label for the darker spice and
darker scooters we use just yes we just
use the model train by capsule bike
share and then applied by applied on the
data for darker scooters and bikes so we
don't have the real label of them yeah
they were more similar to members than
okay so the last analysis what has was
hot spot analysis so as I explained one
of the major concerns about Darko's
Baker's was their improper parking in
public places
blocking pedestrians and disabled so in
this analysis district Department of
Transportation was interested in
providing some biking racks for in order
that these bikes these tacos but these
tacos bus can be parked in proper places
and also in general as you might know
this kind of data is very
a good source for finding out where most
of the bike trip starts and where they
are ended so we kind of use this data
for finding where is the hot spot
locations for packs so in order to do
this analysis we use a density based
special clustering called DBS scan so to
cluster the entry pop ductless bikes so
so tibial scan as I mentioned the
density based clustering which uses two
parameters epsilon which is the distance
maximum distance for costing two points
together and then another parameter is
the minimum number of points to consider
a points cluster so these are the two
parameters again definition so one of
the advantages this clustering is that
this is robust to outliers so basically
you don't need to cluster every point
which was important in this case one of
the disadvantages was that it cannot
consider clusters with different
densities and as you might know these
darker spikes and darker scooters the
trips are relatively the dense the
density of the trips are really
different in different words so for
example worth seven and eight they don't
have they don't have many trips started
or ended at them
so because of equity we had to use
different parameters for different words
to basically find candidate locations
and
and across DC kind of uniformly so we
tested different numbers as you can see
when you change the numbers the number
of clusters that is found by the
clustering algorithm change for example
if you increase the number the minimum
number of points the cluster the number
of cluster it can we found a decrease so
we kind of played with these numbers and
then we come up with a 25-meter as
epsilon and then for different words of
TC you can see the eight words of DC we
use different minimum points so that we
can have candidate facilities in each of
the parts so and this kind of shows the
final
so they're great points shows the end of
the trips and then the red points shows
the center of the clusters the points
that are basically closer to the center
of the clusters and you can see because
of using different and numbers basically
the densities are different across that
they see the density of the cluster
clusters there are other visualizations
so another method for hotspot analysis
with hexagonal pinning so this is
another method for visual is a
visualizing large data set when you have
a large set of data points overlapping
each other so again this is by providing
a grid over the map and then basically
calculating the counting the number of
trips that were inside of each hexagon
so this is another visualization for
showing which areas have more dense and
of the trips or trip starts so these are
two other visualizations so the first
one is the heat map of start location of
trips versus time of day so here again
you can select
day and then you can zoom in to see
where are the locations that usually
trip starts and the other one is
basically the court plot so here it
shows the inflow and outflow from each
of the world so you can select the time
of day and then the word number and then
this court plot shows basically so this
is Ward 1 and this part shows the what
percentage of troops basically coming
out of the Ward 1 and this part the
white part shows the which parts which
percentage of the trips are coming into
the Ward 1 so basically this is our end
of presentation thank you everyone for
coming
[Applause]
yes the doc was
some human where the location of the
bikes are Oh No so no it's not from API
so the data we used here is just trip
data provided by a ductless operators so
they had to provide the dot monthly
reports of the trips so basically the
day the trip data included the start
location and location and then some
distance measurement and the time of an
time yeah time off the day yes yeah each
company has an app that they use that
you can rent the vehicles through and
then also we have an API a public API
that they feed us that's available to
the public that shows similar
information that shows where all the
bikes can be aware of bikes that aren't
able to be rented are
metric you see like where users are
trying to open up
or what where users open up an app to
try and find buttons and we're yeah so
one of the so we don't receive that data
another thing that like we wouldn't want
to have it they necessarily but one of
the questions we asked initially was
kind of the the foss open rates like if
you open the app and you see that okay
well I can't use it so I'm going to
close it like that what does that say
about the availability of the vehicles
one thing I didn't mention about the
pilot is up until the end of this year
companies are only allowed to have 400
vehicles throughout the district so
there's a cap on how many vehicles in
which could influence some of the
availability
so I think you may have already answered
this actually but I'm curious if the
companies give you any information on a
script like a Super User just like I
would imagine they would not give you
any sort of like person identifiable
information on the users of the product
but if they could give you any sort of
like you know anonymized ie D level
information like can you see if like
there's like a certain subgroup of it
earlier
users or is it just all just yeah so we
are also receiving user data basically
it's a table that shows a anonymized
user number and then how many user ID
number and then how many trips they're
taking so we get kind of an idea of if
there are some people who are taking you
know hundreds of trips there in the
month and some that are like tried it
once so we do have an idea of kind of
the the distribution of usage no we
don't get any demographic data it's it's
the companies are very different so if
we think back to when we had the pedal
bikes there were two companies that were
international there were some companies
that were a national that were newer
they had different ways of interacting
with the agency and what the city they
had different ways of interacting with
their customers so there was definitely
variation across the the companies I
think that at this point over the course
of the year the companies are kind of
aligned to a more similar pattern of
operations which is great for D not
great for I think the customers as well
but yeah there is definitely differences
across the companies just based on and
how they operate
so we didn't have a date on proper
parking or not we just used we were
interested in knowing how like what was
the duration of the parking for example
a bike is parked for six hours two days
or something like that so it's kind of
assessing like how well maintained if
these systems are so basically operators
are living them for themselves or they
are doing some rebalancing order to like
yeah yeah we were able to do any
analyses to understand in pepper parking
or not that was one of the kind of
research questions that we had in the
initial drafting of the research
statement what is improper parking and
one of the things that we identified is
if it's not if it's not leaving a clear
space in the public in the public space
like it's it's obstructing travel or if
it's hazard a safety hazard so things
are what we identified as pub improper
parking but there's not necessarily a
way to track that with our data
it depends on the computer as far as I
know it depends on the companies so so
for example I know line bike straight
they just provide like they are going to
incentivize people to gather the
scooters and charge them and then return
them in the system in the morning so
they just pay like some of them they
just use like basically the economy yeah
but some of them they just gathered like
recharged
yeah yeah yeah so you mean like for
example of a controlling problem for
just gathering the bikes that they are
not like they are yeah it's like a very
industrious juicer could develop an
algorithm to identify areas where
there's low batteries and then go out
and collect those vehicles yeah I
thought it was
[Music]
I notice is that that age profile the
users of topless bikes versus topless
scooters is very different and
at some point if you actually if you
mean to do research on precisely how
safe these things are it'll be
impossible to address those questions
without noting the age at which folks
are using the uses or any kind of
relationship with these things like
Holly you know how many more hazards
lined up to deal with on the road I
think my brain is full but you know
folks coming at you when they're 14
years old and you know just curling down
the street with no helmets on a scooter
it's just something I see a lot on my
way home from work yeah safety is a big
concern for us scooters in the the
roadway as well as screws on the
sidewalk so there's a lot of unnecessary
new mobility option for DDOT but also
for the country and there's a lot of
cities that are grappling with how do we
either enforce or educate or both around
scooters
on that point what kind of data are you
getting on accidents and how are you
cross-referencing everything else yeah
so one of the things in the pilot is
what data to collect that's one of
things we learned right so we initially
had an idea one at some trip data we
wanted some information on safety and we
developed a data standard for that over
the course of the year that we were
collecting data we kind of streamlined
what we're asking for and asked for more
details in areas that were getting more
questions around in trying to flush out
the data that we needed to do the proper
analyses so over the first year we were
getting pretty we're getting kind of
aggregated numbers of incidents that
report it so we're not really sure if
they were crashes or if they were just
incidents that the user report to the
company as we move forward we've asked
for more details so the severity of the
incident whether they're an MPD report
was filed in the location of the
incident so we're trying to understand
better the impact that were that we're
seeing on the on the road most of our
safety crash data is coming in from MPD
from Metropolitan Police Department
crash reports that's typically how we
understand incidents in all other modes
we don't want to us airily overburden
this new mobility option but we do want
to get some more information since it is
so new across the across the country any
and cross-referencing it at all with
anything else
finding anything interesting um so the
the day that we have thus far is pretty
much just aggregate numbers so we
haven't we collected maybe a month or
two of the the newer set of data so I
can't really do much now something quite
yet
ten miles per hour which is
so Frank the questions about collision
data are you guys trying to utilize some
of that collision data to get more of an
idea of that house to be plays a role
because it doesn't seem like something
that I you guys displayed to us has
yeah so it's honestly a new regulation
it's more of a were enforcing the
regulation that was already there
so because scooters are considered a
personal mobility device similar to a
Segway there's always been on the books
that they're not allowed to go over ten
miles an hour so because some of the
vehicles didn't have speedometers and
because we don't have people out there
with speed guns giving tickets to
scooter riders we or putting it putting
the onus on the companies to find ways
to make sure they're limiting the speed
to ten miles per hour so that's kind of
the the newness of the regulation so
we're not necessarily collecting any
data on the speed of the vehicles work
and also we've asked the companies is it
possible to if there is an incident on
an electric assist vehicle or
electrified vehicle that they can
provide the speed at which the vehicles
traveling if there was an incident and
that to me that they have not
necessarily been able to do so it's
something that maybe in continued
conversations and as their technology
improves that could be something that we
add to the mix but we don't have that
data currently
you
[Applause]